on the topic of the day and you served
in the Whip's office you know the
information that a Whip's office
generally holds about the behavior of
the back Banshees allegations of drug
abuse of inappropriate behavior
if the conserved equips office currently
holds information on its members along
those lines right now it should be put
into the public domain or given to the
relevant authorities surely well no I
think depends on the severity of the
offense or the activity in some cases
some of this recently reported activity
is obviously totally inappropriate but
the individuals concerned have
apologized but there might be for all I
know
offenses are more serious in which case
perhaps the Whip's office should take it
further but just in terms of the
severity of the offense let's try and
work out where we are in a sliding scale
you know in proper language I'll just
keep it to ourselves a bit of a group
that's fine but you know actual sexual
assault of course we'd report that well
we're seeing this right across a whole
area of activity not just the Harvey
Weinstein reports but we hit reports
today that the in the theatres and other
areas of public entertainment and
photographers behaving badly I think
it's obviously incumbent on members of
parliament to behave properly but as I
said certain areas where I think an
admission of guilt
and a full public apology is right but
if the whips are privy to much more
serious allegations where an offense
actual legal offence might be called
perhaps they then have to take it
further
of course it's it's not just the former
members of the cabinet backbenchers I
mean yesterday we had the Environment
Secretary in the process of making a
rather ill judge joke appealing to
suggest that women who are the victims
of sexual abuse had in some way lost
some of their dignity yes I was
listening live to that today broadcast
you could say the whole audience that we
were all was to blame because they all
they all rather laughter as did Lord
kenick did you but Michael go for
subsequently a pop yes but this is all a
question judgment is in Martha go was
quite rightly I think very rapidly
given a fulsome apology for a statement
which I think at the time was my person
I thought at the time was wrong and he's
been quite right about that but a law
has not been broken and he's quite
rightly come out and apologized very
quickly in a fulsome manner but I think
was worth noting I'm put making them
appear just a little or has been broken
you know an apology is sufficient well
this is all obviously a very gray area
it depends the severity of what you're
talking about and we're talk about
hyperventilate all is that if a person
is found to have behaved inappropriately
inappropriate language or something like
that and it does Apollo admit first of
all the very important MIT that wrong
has been done and then apologizes in my
opinion that should probably bring it
into it but as I said you're asking me
or you're you're hinting that the whips
are privy to knowledge or much worse
offenses which I don't know about if
those are actually illegal then I think
it would be appropriate to go further to
higher authorities and ultimately the
police will be speaking to Philip done a
little later than the program will put
that point to him but possibly have you
of course you're known as something of a
brexit II and I think it's fair to say
and your colleague Charlie elphic is
asking the tragedy for a billion pounds
to prepare know for an ordeal brexit I
mean shouldn't we be starting to spend
on the infrastructure that will require
if we do crash out of the European Union
without a deal well I think all this
sort of no deal and crash out is all
rather dramatic talk I was a signature
to a letter with some very senior people
two weeks ago saying that given the
European Union's flat refusal to
negotiate the end commercial
relationship it would be sensible to
tell them formally that we assume from
now that was middle of November sort of
middle October that we will be moving to
WTO rule terms from the 30th of March
2019 should they then come back to us
and want to talk about
an all-encompassing free-trade deal that
would be great but as Charlie quite
rightly said in your clip if this would
be prudent insurance many would give
clarity to all parties just just let me
be the creep one point if would give
clarity all in all the parties not just
those who use these facilities but those
who deliver them so for instance
customers and exercise would know that
they should be gearing up for this
eventualities and we should be invest as
Charlie says anyway we should be
investing this stuff we should have an
absolute world class I just want to pick
points a lot you know David David Davis
this week landed himself in something in
some hot water when he suggested that
yes the Commons will have a vote are on
whatever we agree or don't agree with
with the European Union but that vote
might take place after the point at
which we leave the European Union I mean
that is a statement of fact isn't it if
the negotiations go up to the wire even
beyond the wire as mr. Davis said to the
Select Committee their only opportunity
for the Commons to vote will be after
we've left the European Union which is
why it will be very prudent now to give
them notice that we are assuming that
the way that talks are being conducted
and they've said now we're going to
we're going to miss the hold of November
we're not going to talk about trade
unless they graciously conceded in the
middle of December so we'll miss most of
December we won't start talking the
insular area that's effectively from the
moment we sent our letter last week
that's three months we should be getting
on with this now as Charlie says if they
then get the signal because they are the
ones that have this huge 71 point eight
billion surplus with us and they're the
ones we'll get clobbered by tariffs
should we impose tariffs then hopefully
they'll come back to us and realize that
the really big issue to talk about is
our future trading relationship that
would be great just in terms of Commons
or on this protocol for help and just in
terms of a process from what you're
saying and you seem to agree with mr.
Davis that despite being promised from
the very beginning that the Commons
would have a vote of significance on
this the vote may take place past the
point at which it would have any
significance
well I think dough came and I think the
government think that's unlikely and
they they say that the talks are
actually going better than the public
image is and they are confident they
will get a deal but the point about
triggering the WTO issue now this he's
not jumping off a cliff this is not some
mad crazy overreaction to the fact that
talks haven't started he's just being
very prudent as Charlie elphic says that
we should have take out an insurance
policy that will give clarity to all our
administrators it will give clarity to
all business for instance if you take
the issue of authorized Deacon opera
operators these these are trucking
organizations that have basically a path
to a swift process we've only got six
hundred and four of those Germany has
over six thousand so if we triggered
this trucking companies could prudently
start lodging bids to take on authorize
economic operator status and that would
speed things up with the customs down
the road it Schurman the European Union
come back and see that we're serious
about this that would be great because
what we all want really is reciprocal
free trade with no tariffs that's the
ideal